there are people in this world today who
believe that gender is purely a social
construct
you i think are not one of those people
to you what are the difference between
men and women
how much of those differences are in
nature and how much is nurture
i guess if we you're asking the question
morphologically or psychologically i
assume you're asking psychologically the
question is what it is
and the answer
sometimes the questions
don't contain with them the trajectory
you take with the answer right so
i think i was asking both
and the fact that both our thing is an
interesting
thing
yeah so you wrote a book
textbook i should say evolutionary
psychology
right yes those both of those words are
in the book title
psychology that's the human mind yes
yeah how much of gender how much of sex
is the human mind
and how much of it is the biology
the way that i phrase it so i i don't
like
um
sort of dividing the world into two
categories things that are biological
versus things that are not biological
um
uh
so the biology is actually defined as
the study of life and life processes and
so at that sort of abstract level
everything we do is biological including
culture and our capacity for culture
which i think is an evolved capacity
that humans have
when you get to the issue of sex and and
gender i mean one
cut at your question is
uh are there universal psychological sex
differences
um and the answer to that question is
yes there are some
so for example
well and this is in in one of your areas
of specialty uh engineering
um one of the interesting things is that
it's called the people's thing
dimension so
do you want an occupation you want a job
that involves
people social interaction
or are you happy with a job that just
involves things mechanical objects or
computer code or whatever
and this is one of the largest
psychological sex differences that that
exists and it's true in every culture
so
in terms of i don't know um magnitude of
effects it's a an effect size of um more
than a standard deviation difference
between the means
um on this psychological sex difference
and so one of the interesting things is
so if you go to places like go to the
most
gender egalitarian cultures in the world
so places like sweden
or norway
which are explicitly
gender egalitarian and and are truly in
many many ways
and but you allow people freedom of
choice the the some of these sex
differences actually get larger the
psychological sex differences and also
assortment into different
uh choices
um now but this this is not something
that i
study i study
mating and
the sex differences if you ask what are
the where in what domains are the sex
differences the largest it turns out
they occur within the domain of mating
and sexuality
so our evolved sexual psychology our
evolved mating psychology is to some
degree
sexually demorphic okay with the
uh very important asterisk that we're
talking about overlapping distributions
so there are some things that so if you
look at human morphology um
we talked about breasts earlier women
have evolved
functional breasts that's functional for
lactation
men don't so there's not no amount of um
culture or social coercion can cause men
to have lactating
breasts
psychologically we don't see
dimorphism that extreme where something
is
literally present in one sex and totally
absent in the other so there's overlap
in the distributions so i mentioned
earlier that
in the mating domain men men more than
women on average prioritize physical
appearance physical attractiveness
relative youth women on average
prioritize resources resource
acquisition qualities that lead to
resource acquisition like status
ambition industriousness and so forth
but there's overlap in the distribution
so some women place the
total priority on how physically
attractive the guy is and
uh some men
view that as a is irrelevant
and and and
so the the point that i'm making is that
there are
there are psychological sex differences
that um makes some people uncomfortable
um but you know it's one of these things
where
i'm
a scientist uh i'm not a
political advocate uh um and so i'm i
adhere to the empirical data
on empirical data are very strong in
these domains so with respect to sex
differences in the mating domain and
sexuality
and things we haven't talked about like
desire for sexual variety and sex
differences in the whole uh
desire for short-term mating
uh huge sex differences there
uh and these have been documented
universally in all cultures so
uh okay now are there uh are there
things that are culture specific or
social cultural overlays onto these
fundamental psychological sex
differences absolutely
um
but
there's also an issue of
levels of analysis levels of abstraction
and how closely you look at the
phenomenon so
quick analogy language so you say well
in china they speak chinese and korea
they speak korean in brazil they speak
portuguese they look how culturally
infinitely variable languages are which
they are at that level
but do humans have a universal human
innate grammar and i think the evidence
points to the answer yes to that at
least
that's what steve pink or paul bloom and
some other
uh others argue so at one level of
abstraction things are infinitely
culturally variable or at least highly
culturally variable and another level of
abstraction there's universality so
here's one example in the mating domain
of this so
margaret mead who is a famous um
anthropologist uh
uh studied the samoan islanders and she
tried to argue basically for the
infinite malleability of things like
gender and gender roles and so forth
she's and she said look at this culture
the in this culture it's the men who
paint their face uh whereas you know in
western cultures it's the women who wear
makeup and so forth well it turns out if
you if you look carefully at the culture
where men paint their face they're
painting a
war paint on their face they're not
they're not
putting on makeup to enhance their cues
to youth and cues to health they're
putting on war paint to make themselves
more ferocious or to demarcate what
tribe they're in what coalition they're
in
and so at sort of one level have a
abstraction you could say well there's
high cultural variability and
application of face paint but on another
level there's really a fundamental
functional difference in the purpose to
which the paint is applied
yeah and then you can abstract the paint
away and
i mean fashion in general just magnify
the characteristics that are appealing
to the opposite sex because war paint is
probably
you know it is you're magnifying the
characteristics that are appealing to
you
the other sex so ability to gain
resources maintain resources
is um
status
status in the hierarchy all those kinds
of things well but well that's that's
part of it but i think another part has
to do with in in that case male
coalitions so we we were
intense this is another unique
characteristic i don't know if you got
into this with richard rang i don't
remember you talking about this but
he's written a lot about male
coalitionary psychology and
humans
cooperate
to an extraordinary
degree in forming coalitions
for the purpose of competing with rival
coalitions and so you even see this with
well you see it in the sports sports
arenas with with team sports you know
where this team wears a different
uniform than that team
uh they have different mascot et cetera
and so part of that is um
male coalitionary psychology
well you so you write again
returning to the textbook now people
should know you wrote a lot of
incredible book that is maybe more
accessible than the evolutionary
psychology textbook but
the the evolutionary psychology textbook
is very accessible yes it is extremely
accessible but that's not your thing and
on amazon you can't
you know
it's a pain it's a textbook it's not you
know it's it's a little bit more of a
pain to purchase which i did i bought
all your books
they're amazing uh we'll talk about a
bunch of them but
in terms of coalitions in chapter 12 of
your evolutionary psychology textbook
you write about status prestige and
social dominance so how do hierarchies
of status and social dominance emerge in
human society
and what's the value of status and
sexual selection we talked about
uh cues of individual health and all
that kind of stuff but what what the
heck's the purpose of status why why
does it matter if i'm the big boss
well uh it matters because
status is uh
influences your access to resources and
your ability to influence other people
within your within your group
and so um this is part of the reason why
women
prioritize a man's social status uh how
he is viewed in the eyes of others
because high status men have access to
to more resources
um
it's interesting that you ask about that
because um i've
just published this is with uh patrick
durkee a former graduate student of mine
we published a couple papers on
precisely this issue where we looked at
what we call human status criteria that
is what are the things that lead to
increases or decreases in status and we
did this in 14 different cultures and we
found some things that are universal but
also some things that are sex
differentiated
um
and so universal things like people
value
trustworthiness they value
intelligence wisdom knowledge
so it's even if you go across cultures
even to the small-scale cultures that we
alluded to earlier
uh there are these wise wise people wise
men and wise women in the culture who
have uh people go to for advice for
wisdom uh and so having a wide range of
knowledge is is a universal status
criterion
and there's some things that are sex
differentiated and they often fall into
the mating domain as well this is where
mating and status are
interestingly related to each other
in that
successful mating increases your status
but having high status also gives you
access to more desirable mates
and so
the game gets harder and harder always
so wait uh
so are we talking about what are the
characters what's the role of power and
wealth
those kinds of things
so you said wisdom is universal yeah
what about wealth and power yeah well uh
well i guess it depends on what you mean
by power so i think of power as the
ability to to influence a large number
of people yeah so um
and this is one of the interesting
things about
the fact that cash economies are so
are evolutionarily very recent
in that we're people are like so so i
guess recently or it's about to happen
uh that um elon musk is gonna
buy a twitter okay or say it happen is
it happening already yeah okay so they
said like the the
wealthiest or one of the wealthiest men
on earth has now purchased the most
influential media platform
um
on earth and so
obviously you or i couldn't um
compete with elon musk and uh
for the purchase of twitter and so
uh the fact that cash economies allow
the stockpiling of unprecedented amounts
of wealth
produces these tremendous power
differentials that that didn't exist in
and over most of human evolutionary
history
um so their wealth is power but you can
also be
um
the power can be attained through other
ways yeah but but but i would say that
the interesting thing about
wealth is that it's
an infinitely fungible resource
so you can
use it and translate it into
many many other things like buying a
buying twitter or
buying a big house or
or even
getting mates or
an artificial um in
i don't know if you don't want to get
into that at all but i need to have
these
sex dolls or
virtual virtual reality sex that some
people are
are developing if you have enough
resources you can purchase things like
that so
you can trans you can translate wealth
into a variety of other tangible things
in ways that that you couldn't
ancestrally
so
that's one really powerful thing but
there is still power
that's correlated but not
integrally connected to wealth which is
like being leaders of nations like
technically the president of the united
states salary is not very high
right
presidents and and then you look you go
outside of that into the half of the
world that's living under authoritarian
regimes you have dictators
and there's uh
those those are very powerful usually
men
and
presumably there's some
value there in the meeting selection
aspect yeah yeah absolutely and and it's
not by chance that um
most of them are men
um and this is
gonna sound
strange or and hopefully not offensive
to people but
um
if you ask the question why are why is
it the case that men are in positions of
power
so much more so than than women well in
part it can be traced to women's mate
preferences so it's one of the sex
differences that women have
over evolutionary time preferred men who
had power status resources
etc and what that has done is it's
created selection pressure on men to
attach a high motivational priority to
clawing their way up the status
hierarchy
and and
studies of time
allocation distribution show this where
men
are they're more willing to sacrifice
their their friends their grandmother
their kin or whatever to claw their way
up to the top of status hierarchies
women much less women
spend more effort maintaining
relationships with their can through
their friends their friend networks and
so forth and so
um and and so in a way uh so
you could say not only
are you uh not only are men in positions
of power more than women now you're
blaming women
for why they are and it's not it's not a
matter of blame but i think that
that what i just outlined is is an
essential part of the causal process the
co-evolution of women's mate preferences
with men's motivational priorities